I want to show you how I became number
one in different fields, [music]
industries, and even broke a world
record, and how you can apply the same
process to winning or getting whatever
it is that you want. My name's Ashi. I
own a portfolio of companies at
acquisition.com that generates $250
million per year in aggregate revenue. I
did a book launch that did $106 million
[music] in a weekend and broke the
Guinness World Record for the fastest
selling non-fiction book of all time.
And so, there's my kind of proof behind
that. So, in this video, I'm going to
explain a core shift in my understanding
of getting what I wanted and [music]
specifically in business. So this will
be a belief breaker for you guys. So I
talk to business owners for a living
every single day like literally every
week and I have for you know decade
plus. And one of the things that drives
me absolutely nuts is the idea of
industry standards. Um so you've
probably heard this people like oh this
is industry standard that's industry
standard. And I'll tell you a real
conversation that might shift this for
you. So there was a company that I
recently met with that was about a $500
million company. So I have a billion
dollar company. All right. And you know
they were efficient but it was an old
school model. So I met with the chiefs
of that business and I met with the
leaders, right? And the entrepreneur who
runs the business wanted me to look at
certain components of how they do things
in terms of acquisition and things like
that. And when I walked them through uh
their acquisition process, I was like,
"Hey, these are some things that need to
change." And there was a lady who was
there who was in charge of probably
maybe half of it. And at least, you
know, it fell under her purview. And as
I would, you know, point out things that
were bad, uh, or like needed
improvement, she kept repeating the same
thing, which is like, well, you know,
we're industry standard. And I was, and
she'd be like, we're meeting industry
standards. And she would get really kind
of flustered. And she kind of, I would
say, maybe to a degree got offended. Uh,
because I was saying, well, you know,
this sucks and this sucks and these
numbers aren't good. Um, and they kept
repeating, we're meeting industry
standards. And so I paused and I was
like, do you wake up in the morning and
just say, I want to be an average
company, right? We are average. Half the
people are better than us and half are
worse. We are average.
Who gives a [__] Right? I don't know
about you, but like I didn't get in the
game, whatever game you're playing, to
be average. Like the average business is
average. The average American is
overweight. They're in debt. They're
divorced. They're depressed. And so the
average business makes almost no money.
Why would I use industry standards,
industry averages, anything like that at
all? And I say this because I have
people who will push back on some of the
things that I talk about with regards to
margin when I think things I talk about
in terms of timeline, when I talk in
terms of pricing, right? And they'll say
something like, well, you know, in HVAC,
it's different or, you know, in SEO it's
a little bit different or you know,
we've got XYZ issue in trucking and it's
different. It's logistics, it's
different. No, it's not. You get what
you tolerate. You get what you accept
and deem good enough. You are the
standard setter. It is the highest and
most important job in the company. And
it is why some companies prevail and
some companies fail. It's the reason
that Jobs was so important for Apple.
Elon was so important for Tesla and XAI
and all the other things that he does.
And like at a certain point, you cannot
actually do anything in the company
except for hold the [__] line. And
the person who should run every
department or every division should be
the person with the highest standards,
right? And this applies to everything,
right? Sales rates, closing percentages,
profit margins, cash flow, the people
you date, the body fat percentage you
hold, how fast you expect something to
get done. Literally everything. Real
quick, I'm going to show you the exact
10-stage road map from zero to 100
million plus that less than 1% of
companies finish. I've now done multiple
times. And so I can say with a lot of
confidence that these are the stages as
headcount increases that you need to get
through. And I broke each of these down
by eight different functions of the
business. What the constraint feels
like, like what are the symptoms of it
when you're going through it. And then
what steps we actually took to graduate.
And we've done this across software,
physical products, uh, service
businesses, brickandmortar, all of this.
And it works. And it's my gift to you.
It's absolutely free. And so the link's
in the description, but you just go
acquisition.com/roadmap.
Just enter your info and it'll spit it
right back to you. All free. So, let me
tell you a story about a billionaire
mentor of mine. Again, had a
conversation many years ago. Um, and he
said this thing to me that I'll never
forget. He said, "Profit is unnatural."
And I was like, "What does he really
mean by that?" He said, "It's common and
normal for people when money is in a
bank account to spend it." And that's
why most people don't have money. He
said so if you have a company and it
makes money and it actually starts to
succeed that success has this constant
pressure of normaly that fights against
it. And so there has to be someone who
holds the line and is like no we will
not spend more but we will keep making
more. We will get more customers and we
will not hire more people. We will find
a way to service these customers better
than we did our last customers without
adding headcount. And we're going to do
it even better, even faster with less.
And so let me tell you another example
uh of something that just happened in
one of our portfolio companies. So uh
they needed to add 15 sales reps uh to
hit their Q1 goals, right? And so the
leader was saying how his plan was to
hire five reps a month, right? Every
single month. And doing it this way, he
said would, you know, stretch the team,
but it would still kind of like, you
know, ensure quality, make sure the
culture wasn't, you know, too stressed,
etc. And honestly, it was a fair plan,
right? But for this business, the extra
sales guys were going to add about 4
million in profit that quarter. that's
how much extra he was going to add just
that quarter. So I pushed back and I
said why can't we do it in a month and
he had a lot of different reasons of and
he kept you know like it'll be cultural
issue I think we'll stretch the team we
might lose other sales in other places
and I kept pushing and pushing but he
had some reasons to come back and
thankfully he's a stud and then after
the meeting he messaged me back and said
two of our guys have bandwidth who are
more senior they can assist the new
manager and onboard three to five guys
each if we do that we can actually do it
in a month and boom $4 million more
potential next year in Q1. on because of
one thing, a higher standard. Just
saying like why does it need to take
that long? Why can't we have like if we
were if we were doing a billion in sales
in this business, we probably wouldn't
say we need to hire five guys uh a
month. No way, right? We'd be like, we
need to start with 50 and maybe add 50
every other week, right? The the it's
just this minimum standard of of
something that you decide is enough or
acceptable. And the crazy part about it
is like we're the ones who decide this
and then we're upset that we don't get
or that we're upset that we got the
fruit of our very low standards. And so
the way that you can kind of know kind
of what your standards are, what the
standard of somebody else on your team
is is how many attack vectors you use to
approach or solve a problem, right? So
it's not about doing the same thing a
100 times. That's not smart, right? It's
about trying to accomplish the same goal
with a hundred different iterations and
angles until one finally gets through,
till you pass the goalie, till you till
you chop down the tree, right? It's
like, well, I'm hitting it this way and
I'm I'm getting rock. It's like, okay,
well then let's try from another angle.
Let's try underneath. Let's see if we
can poison the tree. Like, whatever we
need to do, like, can we reach out to
our network and give a $100,000 bounty
for another SDR? Is there a company with
a large SDR team that doesn't make as
much as us so we can buy? Can we can we
hire five recruiters to speed up the
process? Can we fly all of the SDRs in
person to get them trained up faster uh
to so we don't lose cultural issues and
we can get them on-ramped in in 3 days
rather than in 30 days? Right? Can the
top two, you know, most experienced guys
who have some blank space have them sub
in? Bingo. Right? All of these have
costs obviously, but of the costs,
they're still worth it. So you're not
getting what you want because you're not
attacking the problems you have enough
times in enough ways. So, you're trying
one or two things and then saying like,
"I tried that and it didn't work. I
tried Facebook ads. You know, I tried
making content. I tried hiring a
salesman and it didn't work." It's like,
"No, it's not that it didn't work. It's
that you weren't skilled enough to make
it work." Very big difference. And so,
you're going to tell me that no one on
earth has ever had the same problem that
you have right now. And no, and of those
many people on earth who've had it, no
one solved it. You have somehow come
across the Gordian knot of problems. No
one has hired more than five SDRs in
this period of time for a company of
this size. Of course, they have and
that's why those people won. And they
didn't just accept that it wasn't
possible within this timeline. And so
the rules that I would encourage you to
live by is that unless the laws of
physics prevent it, consider it mental
handicaps that your competition gets to
live by and measure themselves by, not a
suggestion, a recommendation, and
certainly not a [__] law. Right?
Industry standards are a handicap that
you let your competitors use and think
they're doing well. That is the gift
that we get as soon as you get out of
this belief. Because if you want to be
average, use industry averages. And most
industry average businesses suck, right?
Why would we look at them to judge
ourselves by like, "Oh, this guy's
completely broke and distracted, has no
idea what he's doing. I should look what
his numbers are and say, oh, we're about
the same." Is that an accomplishment?
Should we be looking forward to
something like that happen? Like if you
want to be the best, use physics and
math and then work backwards. And so I
think something that'd be really good to
to finish on is this great piece uh by
Jeff Bezos. And I want to read it to you
because I think it just really drives
this point home. Differentiation is
survival and the universe wants you to
be typical. This is my last annual
shareholder letter as CEO of Amazon and
I have one last thing of utmost
importance I feel compelled to teach. I
hope all Amazonians take it to heart.
So, here's a passage from Richard
Dawkins extraordinary book, The Blind
Watchmaker. It's about the basic fact of
biology.
Staving off death is a thing that you
have to work at. Left to itself, and
that is what it is when it dies, the
body tends to revert to the state of
equilibrium within its environment. If
you measure some quantity such as
temperature, the acidity, the water
content, or the electrical potential in
a living body, you'll typically find
that it's marketkedly different from the
corresponding measure in the
surroundings. Our bodies, for instance,
are usually hotter than the
surroundings. And in cold climates, they
have to work hard to maintain that
differential. When we die, the work
stops. The temperature differential
starts to dissipate, and we end up the
same temperature as our surroundings.
Not all animals work so hard to avoid
coming into equilibrium with their
surrounding temperature, but all animals
do some comparable work. For instance,
in a dry country, animals and plants
work to maintain the fluid content of
their cells, work against a natural
tendency for water to flow from them
into the dry outside world. If they
fail, they die. More generally, if
living things didn't work actively to
prevent it, they would eventually merge
into their surroundings and cease to
exist as autonomous beings. This is what
happens when they die. While the passage
is not intended as a metaphor, it's
nevertheless a fantastic one and very
relevant to Amazon. I would argue it's
relevant to all companies and all
institutions and to each of our
individual lives, too. In what ways does
the world pull at you in an attempt to
make you normal? How much work does it
take to maintain your distinctiveness to
keep alive the thing or things that make
you special? I know a happily married
couple who have a running joke in their
relationship. Not infrequently, the
husband looks at his wife with faux
distress and says to her, "Can't you
just be normal?" They both smile and
laugh. And of course, the deep truth is
that her distinctiveness is something
that he loves about her. But at the same
time, it's also true that things would
be often easier, take less energy if
they were a little more normal. Right?
This is this phenomenon happens at scale
at all levels. Democracies are not
normal. Tyranny is the historical norm.
If we stop doing all the continuous work
that is to needed to maintain our
distinctiveness in that regard, we would
quickly come into equilibrium with
tyranny. We all know that
distinctiveness, originality is
valuable. We're all taught to be
yourself. What I'm really asking you to
do is to embrace and be realistic about
how much energy it takes to maintain
that distinctiveness. The world wants
you to be typical in a thousand ways. It
pulls at you. Don't let it happen. You
have to pay a price for your
distinctiveness, and it's worth it. The
fairy tale version of be yourself is
that all your pain stops as soon as you
allow distinctiveness to shine. That
version is misleading. Being yourself is
worth it, but don't expect to be easy or
free. You'll have to put energy into it
continuously. The world will always try
to make Amazon more typical to bring us
into equilibrium with our environment.
It will take continuous effort, but we
can and we must be better than that. You
have to hold the [__] line. Like this
is the last letter that Jeff Bezos
wrote. And can you think about like of
all the things that he wanted to say,
the thing that he chose to leave on was
the line was this is the standard. This
is what makes us different. And of
course it's going to take work. Of
course, it's going to take more ways to
solve the problem. It might cost
millions more in order to do the better
solution than the easy solution. But
like I I if I could just transfer this
one thing like you can tell how good
someone will be as an entrepreneur by
the standards they keep for themselves.
They continue to push back and say like
why can't it be faster? Why can't it be
easier? And there's famous, you know,
uh, stories of, you know, Steve Jobs
putting the phone book on the desk and
saying it has to fit in there. And
people saying like, "It's never been
done before, right?" And you've got Elon
Musk going on, you know, on the
manufacturing line saying, "This could
have two bolts." And they're like,
"There's no way. No one's done it
before." And he's like, "Why? Break it
down to physics. Why can't we do this?"
Right? And so when someone pushes back
on you and says like, you know, we can't
hire that fast. It's like, why? What
physical law is preventing us from
hiring that fast? If another company
who's 20 times our size can hire 100
people a day, why is it taking us a year
to do it? Right? what choice are we
choosing or what cost are we not
choosing to bear that we could bear to
make the investment to pull our future
forward and I think it's like that push
that relentless energy the drive to to
choose to be different right to choose
to to to hold a value the perfect value
that you have as the ideal and then to
strive continuously and though
imperfectly to try and live that out and
I think of that as like the reason you
win or you don't win and again I'm not
talking table stakes if you want to
average then just look at industry
averages, right? Look at industry norms,
industry standards. But most businesses,
if you looked at the the the average
business in the US, they break even. The
median business owner almost makes no
money, right? And so it's like why would
we measure ourselves by that? We have to
by very definition reject the vast
majority of what other people do in
order to achieve what other people
can't. And I think that that is like
like I would I would encourage you to be
less reasonable. And I would say that it
has been a skill that has served me
well. I mean, you can imagine having
saying, "Hey, we I want to break the
world record that every other person who
has had a book has had massive media
empires. They've had big deals. They had
national media behind them for
presidents and monarchs who released
books." And I'm saying, I'm just some
guy in America saying like, "Let's see
if we can do more than all of them." And
we did. We [__] did, right? We
outsold Prince Harry, Obama combined
within 24 hours. And to be fair, please
don't kill me for, you know, having some
point of disrespect for whatever secret
nations exist, right? But I'm only
saying this to to make the point, which
is like when I when I set that goal
originally, can you imagine the amount
of people who were like, I don't know if
that's realistic, man. Like, hey, that's
a really big number. Like, have you
really thought I mean, like, but what if
it doesn't happen? I had someone ask me
that. They said, well, what if we don't
hit the goal? And I said, we dare
greatly, [__] That's the point.
Like, so what if we don't hit the goal?
It doesn't mean we don't we we give
ourel an excuse to not try, but like try
in earnest, not say like, oh, we're
going to do this and we hope this
happens. It's like, no, we want to have
five different versions of this thing
going wrong and it's still hitting the
goal. And so I I say this because like
the goals that I have and probably the
goals that you have, never apologize for
them. They're they're it's normal for
them to be unreasonable, but you don't
need to be reasonable. The world wants
you to be reasonable. It's like you need
to be unreasonable. You need to stick
your your feet in the mud and there's a
certain amount of stubbornness that's
required. And I think part of the reason
that Peter Teal and some of these great
investors talk about phenomenal
entrepreneurs is that they have
sometimes they don't have super high
agreeableness. Is that they don't need
consensus. They don't need everyone else
to like them because they they believe
what they believe. Right? And the thing
is is that in order to have an outsized
return in anything, you have to bet
against conventional wisdom, right? And
conventional wisdom can be right. And so
that means that fundamentally either
you're an idiot or you're right and
you're early. And that's where you get
rewarded. And so you have to think like
at least the process I come down to is
always like what physical law of reality
prevents us from selling this many
books. And that's why it came down to
like all right we'll have multiple
generators. Like if we don't have power
we can't sell books. We have to make
sure that we have backups for internet.
If we don't have internet we can't sell
books. Okay do we have enough books to
sell? We got to print them. Okay great.
We have to have logistics that we have
hundreds and hundreds of people ready to
actually ship those books out. Okay. If
we have each of these things, then all
that it really takes is enough people to
see it and an offer enough that is
compelling that makes sense for a big
enough audience to say yes.
That's it. And so you have these
problems in your business. You're not
cash flowing enough. You're not hiring
fast enough. You're not your your your
price isn't what you want it to be. If
you believe and you can reason it to say
like what prevents us from doing this,
I think that that's where you can get
these special outsized returns. I think
that's where you can have the
unreasonable accomplishments. But it
comes first from having unreasonable
conviction that you will hold the line,
that this will be the standard that you
have. And the fact that no one else has
ever done it before means absolutely
nothing to you because there's no reason
that they couldn't have done it. And
good on you for ignoring the fact of
their mediocrity.